what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today you know how much we
love squid game so off a lot of requests
we are going to watch from the amazing
youtube channel i'm sure you've heard of
this channel before mr beast 456
thousand dollars squid game in real life
yeah i'm very much looking forward to
this i've seen plenty of mr beast
feeding i've never actually done a
reaction in any mr beast videos but i've
seen a lot and i i i the amount of money
he that he they spent is insane
but guys i think everyone was sending me
messages all over social media should be
a healthy recovery still a little bit
out of it but i feel much better this is
all just to say that's why i'm wearing
my most comfortable shirt which is full
of holes while going on the internet to
a youtube video for thousands of people
to see me looking more like a homeless
man than i already knew
let's okay you got that chris pratt
power you're good let's get into it
people chris pratt that's who i would
cast as my gee hun and the american
remake perfect segway
check out that video
i love that this video which i heard i
saw on social media it's got like a
million views in nine minutes or
something like that but it cost like 50
million in uh less than a day or
something some crazy number so they've
more than made back the money it cost me
it's always so here by this point yeah
[Music]
i recreated every single set from squid
game in real life in whichever one of
these 456 people survives the longest
wins 456 grand
the first game we're gonna play is red
light green light and they have 30
minutes to cross the red line on the
other side of the huge room so without
further ado green light
[Music]
this is [ __ ] nuts
oh oh
and as you can see every single player
has a device strapped to them that when
they're eliminated it pops uh chris you
want to have a chance at one red light
i know for sure this guy moved green
light
squib game
oh yo they're dropping okay now some
people are getting out you got to get a
better spot for the next red leg right
you're fine 30 people have gotten out so
far if they move right now they're out
they have to hold this position until we
say green light and i can take all the
time i want because we still have 23
minutes left we should get a green light
going this guy's doing a full squat
green light
green light oh they all stopped red
light
oh
no you push my glasses up okay do it
slowly though be careful
let the others clear the path for me you
literally haven't even moved uh a couple
steps we'll see if it pans out green
light
yellow
red light
oh
that we got her the yellow light worked
that was diabolical to throw a yellow
light out there since zero six seven was
a big part of the show i'll let you say
green light green
red light
yeah it would be funny if she just got
out
as you can see over 100 people have been
eliminated
wow green light
red light
oh that was a loud one
there it is hey
green light
red light
i love the weird gate everybody to adopt
spirits do or die for most these people
everyone look up at the tv you have four
minutes and 20 seconds left yeah that's
the number four
we have our first two finishers over
here
green light
red light sorry baby
baby all right we have five people
across the finish line now we are all
kind of screwed if you don't run faster
you're right green light yep you're
right
only
two minutes remain carl makes me way too
nervous
green light
red light
oh
homeboy was not caught you guys see that
[ __ ] let's go back really quick is he
technically
he should have been over the line he's
not over the line he'd be celebrating if
he was over the line i mean his
look at his leg
he called red light
oh
he's moving he was moving
he should be eliminated i demand to
recount can we just say like look how
awesome it is they built this whole set
together geez they don't even take an
opening 20 seconds just
just to go look what we're doing
my goodness
we have under one minute remaining
time's kicking green light
red light
you have stepped on the line you are
good you're good you're good
red light
oh what a dick move
you're definitely out dude i knew that
would work green light
[Applause]
definitely so many of you just got out
they gotta run faster they've gotta you
gotta sprint three lines only one guy
had this mask
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
surviving red light green light
so if you look at this tv you'll see
that only
232 of you survived if you look above
your head you'll see the 456 thousand
dollars you're competing for god it's
insane to me to think that when this
happened in the show it was like whoa if
only more people knew that what the how
the actual game went and what was at
stake they would have played and more
people would have passed and i'm like
you tell me still 200 people got
eliminated well that's the thing is
every time i see one of those videos on
youtube of like how to survive the squid
game i'm like with a game like very like
green light there is no how-to you just
gotta stop at the right time or you're
dead it's so easy to not stop at the
right time oh boy now let's move on to
honeycomb in honeycomb everyone gets a
needle in a cookie with a different
shape on it and they have 10 minutes to
remove the shape from the cookie but if
they break the shape they're eliminated
right all right so everybody i'm gonna
need you to get in the line in front of
one of these question marks
oh you don't even get to choose
the middle basically you don't think
it's umbrella umbrella did you even
watch it again
reveal shape number one
reveal the second symbol
yeah
look at how hard they're kidding if i
was you i'd be getting pretty nervous
reveal it
team triangle
chris girl for it
we all know what it is
i know umbrella
thank god we didn't get the umbrella
[Music]
would the licking method work
even though
everyone's going to try and find out so
you have plotters
yeah
the challenge is underway
you just hear them all scraping
[Music]
ah
i hate my life
oh i was taking it out of the tin and it
just snapped in half let's see it
[Music]
how cruel
yeah they're all trying it okay
[Music]
sorry bud
look at this we have a successful
triangle congratulations
what jimmy doesn't know cause i brought
a lighter and i'm gonna drop it for
somebody
what what
[Music]
one and a half minutes remaining
let's get it baby yeah
yeah
oh my gosh this is the first perfect
umbrella i've seen
oh yeah easy peasy six seven okay
she passed she does have plot armor who
is this 67 jesus christ they hire a
goddamn supermodel to be here just like
yours i think she's a supermodel right
in korea or something the actors who
plays it yeah yeah is she a model i
think oh holy crap her acting chris has
got to be so distracted
and i saw zero zero one earlier and that
guy looked like he was pretty old so
maybe they did try and match everyone to
their number almost there so close 30
seconds
oh my god
are you serious
three
two
and just like that all these players
have been eliminated but don't worry
because they're all walking away with 2
000 in cash
[Music]
and if you leave in the next five
minutes i'll give you four thousand
dollars let's weed out some of the weak
people four thousand dollars
and with that i'm gonna need you all to
split up into groups of ten we have them
form teams because next up is tug of war
this could determine your chance at half
a million dollars we needed the
strongest people and the smartest people
we have intelligence skill and brawn we
try to recruit the biggest people so we
can get real strong and pull the ropes
out
okay i just sent three people off we got
ten now let's go let's go i should have
taken the four grand we now have 12
different groups of 10 people let's move
on to the next game and now let's decide
who faces who
okay we're gonna draw one from here six
we'll just draw this one five okay
follow me to the bridge
holy [ __ ]
holy crap
i gotta pause this just to look at the
set they've gotta be tricking us with
something here they've got to have like
they look like they're right down
they're the actual people right is that
them yeah there's got to be like a
mirror or some [ __ ] wow that is [ __ ]
nuts yeah this i mean that shot from
below made this look absolutely towering
oh boy how much money this costs beyond
the price
all right jesus christ a game of talk
award team six versus team five team
five on three one two three
you fall on the phone or your flag
crosses to the other team's side it's
like freaking star wars
are you ready yeah yeah
all right three skip a few go go
power
oh it's going to team five right now you
gotta do the balance why is someone
doing the thing from the show
oh there they are there
[Music]
congratulations team five you have all
moved on
team number two versus team number
they seven happy team seven and two head
on out you keep me alive i'm gonna get
the money
[Applause]
this team's winning go
oh it's already on right side let's
check in on zero six seven and the show
you won so let's see if it works here
and carl we have zero six seven you
should just lose oh no give a motivation
come on carl
it's over here it crossed
[Music]
sir can you come over here why don't you
draw don't look grab one from here and
one from here and then grab one from
here team number four versus team number
10.
if i was you guys i'd be terrified
because they have four five six he's
literally the main character let's go
one damn it's intense yeah earring and
everything
oh it's going over five
dude that guy is all about this
oh [ __ ]
no
no
oh they all just fell
obviously we have no way of rigging it
but four five six and zero six seven
both survived tug of war i'm so
surprised because i was literally just
thinking that
he knows he [ __ ] knows my first
thought was are they somehow controlling
the narrative on this because yeah the
two main characters are winning right
now yeah yeah i'm not saying woo yeah
forget their numbers it's a problem all
right man i'll take his word for it
either way it's a really super
entertaining ass video nine versus
eleven nine eleven oh boy
versus team 11. they went so hard that
this happened they are going all out
look at them
don't let him oh yes look at that
oh
took us from 120 people down to 60. and
remember only one of these people is
walking away with 456 thousand dollars
all right everybody we have more
attention as you guys know from squid
games game number four is marbles
wow
i don't know if i'd be cheering because
instead of letting you pick your partner
we're gonna make you partner with your
best friend throughout this entire
challenge we've been monitoring who
you've been talking to the most and
we're gonna make you partner up with
them
four three one
according to this you two are roommates
and best friends we did our research i
have to come home to the house we live
in at the end of the day we're gonna be
a bit awkward we wouldn't be able to do
it without you we couldn't have done it
without each other i'm glad i'm with you
at the end i mean though if i want let's
say we were in this position and if i
happen to win yeah i'd come home 456
thousand dollars
i would at the very least give you 500
bucks thanks yeah oh dude that's so
sweet i appreciate it for helping you
get all that weight and i'd shut down
the channel and you would have no more
source of income that's right yeah you
wouldn't need to work anymore you know
i'd be stuck and then i'll go on my own
experiment you know be on the streets
and then get sucked into a real squid
game and then wells fargo would call you
and be like you haven't touched your 500
in one year
is there something we can do to help you
no i don't deserve it i don't want to
use your blood money it's just 500.
it's not that life-changing i mean you
pay a bill at least come on and they
have to agree on a game to play against
their best friend 20 marbles lets them
move on but by winning they eliminate
their best friend go ahead and start the
timer
you can play whatever game you want you
need 20 to leave a lot of pairs went
with marvel games that were played in
sweet games odd
even
otter even even one
[Music]
[Music]
what is this game we're throwing it at
the bricks right if you get the middle
one right there that's one point if you
hit the brick in the behind then it's
three points everything else is no
points until like the clock runs down
whoever has the most points
all right well good luck with your game
you're doing even odds for all of it yo
he looks so intense he's got one level
sure
oh he got it oh my gosh oh
congratulations on winning i'll see you
in the next round
buddy you're good okay none of us died
for me yeah it's gonna be okay we
promised each other we were not gonna
like screw each other over i didn't even
know we were gonna be this close i'm
doing this for my family
but i'm nervous
the best man's gonna win best man man i
really hope this place matches one of
their childhood homes
don't look at me
what no
the supermodel light armor
[Music]
i'll give you the honor of eliminating
your best friend
it doesn't hurt
before i eliminate you i'm gonna let the
viewers know that someone random that
subscribes the next seven days is
getting ten thousand dollars so if you
haven't already hit the subscribe button
okay can i do it go for it just sit
right there i wanna just be able to
throw money at people
they're so dramatic so if you haven't
already subscribe you can win 10 grand
what game are we playing
a minute and 15 seconds remain when that
hits zero if you're in here you're
eliminated
what's up man
[Music]
what do you mean you're literally i'm
both about to get eliminated oh
what's that why'd you do that you sure
yeah
thank you sir
[Music]
he gave it up so the guihon could
progress
the time has hit zero wow what a good
friend
[Music]
congratulations on surviving marbles at
this point in the real show there was an
all-out brawl to thin the numbers so
instead we're gonna play dachy you have
to use this blue piece of paper to flip
that red one on the ground by throwing
it the first 16 of you to flip your red
square moves on to glass bridge which is
personally my favorite game everyone
throw
yeah how are they going to do glass
brush
i gotta say it's brilliant that they're
playing this game instead of the prison
right like they managed to include the
first game yes from the show when you're
like what is going on here they managed
to include it without having to resort
to them actually pulling off some
violent ass game amongst the players
yeah to ruin the lighthearted fun of
this video well this will probably be
the hardest game anybody has to play all
day and while they're fighting for their
chance in this competition i want to
tell you guys about brawl stars will
help fund this video which cost over
three and a half million dollars thank
you so much
[Music]
is a mobile game you can play at home on
the go in this arena wherever you want
against millions of people across the
world
[Applause]
oh we got some
congratulations
it's three minutes of adrenaline filled
mayhem and they have 12 different game
modes including their own battle royale
which is kind of similar to what we're
doing here
wow that is
well
what are your thoughts on brawlstars
that's pretty fun it's a mobile game you
can download it on android or apple i
didn't tell him to say this
he's just seen enough ads
no the main characters are right as you
can see you see the brawl stars logo he
did it they have over 50 different
characters you can play from a vintage
driven robot to a cactus named spike
that kind of looks like nolan
and like all our contestants here are
leaving with two thousand dollars for
free today every single person that
plays brawl stars in the next seven days
i will personally be giving you a free
prize so if you haven't already go
download it if you yelled thank you
brawl stars before you throw i hear
you'll flip it thank you
oh it worked for him oh my god it's true
thank you bro
and for the 14 of you that didn't flip
it i'm gonna have to eliminate you
oh that was so in sync oh my gosh now
can all of you winners turn around
thank you jesus christ and now you can
turn around again we just filled the
room with 16 different mannequins and
here's the thing they're actually in a
random order and the numbers on them are
in korean and the number they get here
is what order they have to cross in
glass bridge in a timely and orderly
fashion you can all go
first come first search what'd you get
oh she got one ah this is smart i think
it's so cool great how there are some
things that don't stay obedient to the
show because they're like well people
saw the show so they'll know yeah you
know like if you ever go first for 16.
yeah yeah
it's so smart to make it a random pic i
love it genius genius stuff
haha i want them to suffer
all right you want to just go ahead and
leave now
everyone has a vest with numbers let's
go to glass bridge
we are now at the glass bridge set and
look at how insane this thing looks it
is amazing and bring out the contestants
i can't wait to see the look on their
faces
man players
come to the glass bridge
[Music]
there's two literally make an amusement
park
really good yeah you can charge so much
you could charge people to do this yeah
all right she survived the first jump
okay they are one try the railing theory
i'm always right okay i don't know if
i'd listen to chris chris this is on you
hey victory
that's scary our first loss if you're
wondering where she just fell don't
worry there's a giant foam pit down
there she's fine well now
now you know now you know left come on
13 minutes guys
we now have three people on the platform
only one else so far
i'm not moving i want somebody past
eight to take the next step past eight i
love that yo hey three minutes that's
going by is anybody willing to go
clock's ticking
no one's willing to go all right let's
see it
come on man you got this
[Music]
come on four or five let's go oh wow
this is going better than i expected
oh you already knew that one
how's it going really well yeah see how
many i've gotten take the next one how
many did you guess right three three
yeah wow yeah honestly it's time someone
else steps up hey every second somebody
doesn't step up that's less time you got
hey if no one crosses i just keep the
money all right three went for it
oh
he just got eliminated all right you
must be such a shitty feeling
seriously
especially this one for three you might
as well keep going clearly you're lucky
oh my god
all right no pushing obviously please
come on oh
damn the bullet he's gone under eight
minutes you still got a ton of ground to
cover yeah he's good
i don't understand why number 10 went in
front of everyone that was dumb
yo to 10 make it again all right ten's
the lucky number six minutes remaining
oh i'm doing this for the girls
no ladies no let's salute all the fallen
people
all right continue under five minutes
left tons of jumps is it gonna get
intense oh that was crazy
no i'm not moving i'm not moving all
right just like we thought would happen
they were refusing to move let's see who
budgets i'm pretty good where i'm at
you're all going to be in the ball pit
soon
oh he got it all right
come on what are y'all big numbers take
a chance under three minutes or four
jumps left somebody's gonna have to do
it you're in a real bad spot run up the
middle numbers take a leap of faith how
you doing back there 15. whatever man we
can all lose you guys better hurry up oh
man [ __ ] come on
down buddy
all right you jumping y'all really got
me scared but hold up bro this is a real
life decision 90 seconds
go
everyone's gonna get eliminated jump
jump
jump
oh
this is god telling me i'm not moving
one minute remaining three weeks one
minute
hey you guys in the back if you're not
here
you're gone i took my legal thing no i'm
gonna stay right here and be cozy
all right y'all going take a leap of
faith
even the strong ones are going to give
out after a certain point yeah go go go
go take a leap of faith
go go go one more
one more jump 20 seconds
one more i already jumped i'm not
jumping i'm not jumping
oh my god guys go
you were gonna fail
no
go
go
i'm gonna play the footage in slow-mo
for the viewers as you can see the timer
is on zero and there were four people
still clearly on the platforms when the
timer hit zero the four people were 16 8
13 and 5. all right so the four losers
can you jump off just jump oh you're
eliminated
you're eliminated you're eliminated get
out of here thank you for coming out and
all of you are moving on to the final
game you know what the shitty part about
this is like in the actual world of
squid game yeah at least you just die
here you gotta go home knowing that if i
just jumped to the other platform
i would still be in the game torture
yourself with that yeah oh man that's
why i could never participate in this
because i was i would spend the rest of
my life regretting it and going
456 thousand dollars i never know that
could have been my 450
oh cause i just didn't jump on the wrong
one they don't give you even a fighting
chance for the whole like lights can't
even yeah tell he can't like throw a
marble yeah yeah right yeah let's go
congratulations on making it to the top
six
to celebrate we made you all steak
dinners now unlike the show this isn't a
real knife this is plastic but you do
have steak everyone make sure you eat up
so you have plenty of energy for this
final game i'm thinking about winning
all of that money right now i'm gonna
probably give most of it to my family
friends that money's coming home with me
giving 100k straight to my mama i'm
feeling great and just blessed to be
here i'm gonna pull through i'm
definitely donating about 10 000 to team
c's which all of you should if you have
the means i won't fold them no pressure
i'm not worried about none of these fog
ain't nobody got nothing on me so i'm
good you want to just go settle this
with the final game let's do it yeah
let's do it let's do it welcome how one
of them was like no i want my stickers
together what we're about to play
musical chairs
let's test my hypothesis raise your hand
if you know how to play squid game
exactly that's why we're
not korean start circling start the
music
carl you can stand and this is one of
the most name-checked games do not look
chris don't look carl isn't looking so
we can't be biased
all right let's see what happens
oh oh he got it i got more man
way more i'm sorry about that wow he is
he is competitive yeah
he took it seriously when he got that
number he has officially been eliminated
and five were made this chair is now
gone
carl start the music
okay
you have full three oh
oh no oh
no more moving come over here
nah he had it he had it at least
oh my gosh and while they're coughing
him up play the music
okay
the music has to be gone
what's about to happen at any second
did not stop the music bring out the
coffin i'm gonna have to pop it man
that's such a sad way to go out it was a
great journey i loved it it was so fun
hop on in the coffin all right now you
can't say this is scripted
no damn that sucks yeah dude that really
sucks get started three people two
chairs one must go
oh
keep it moving no you gotta keep moving
got to keep moving
[Applause]
against me they went against me
open up the coffin thank you for coming
out man i loved your energy at the start
of this video we had 456 people and now
we're down to these two
okay how are you feeling that the fact
that they're not actually playing the
real scorpion um i've kind of wished
that they had attempted to teach
everybody so that we could have seen it
i mean i i did find myself during the
show wondering how could you play this
with like a bunch of people if you look
at the narrative of the actual show like
they don't even really play square game
they just find each other yeah
yeah
you guys gotta keep moving the entire
time no stopping and hovering this will
determine which one of you wins 456
grand quote kick the music on
i let it let it play a little bit carl
let's let him let's let him soak in it
carl's not looking at them he has no
idea where they are on the chair
somebody's going to get 456 000
oh
[Applause]
yeah nicely done
oh my god if it makes you feel better
i'm gonna give you ten thousand dollars
for coming in second oh you're kidding
no and with that zero seven nine you
just won 450 jesus christ that's so much
money oh and officially won the very
first squid game in real life ever
congratulations
if you haven't already hit the subscribe
button you have seven days to win ten
thousand dollars and obviously massive
shout out to the creator of squid game
we took huge inspiration from the show
and i genuinely appreciate it huge
inspiration more than this version
of the damn thing
just with the last grim social
without death
without the death and the
horrific
like socio-economic plight
well that was a very entertaining video
it looked like
three and a half million dollars for
sure oh wow absolutely that was the
first time we're learning about a
sponsored segment of that was money well
spent sponsors this is one of the most
successful videos of all time on youtube
oh yeah no wonder they ponied up to make
this happen the only thing i wish they
had included in this this is a very
challenging video to put together i mean
like the sets look great obviously we
love the hell out of this video as
everything brought to life i wish they
had taken time to get to know
some of the players beforehand for us
even though it would have made this
video longer and it might have made it a
little bit predictable yes that's the
problem that's why i'm like immediately
going it's good they didn't do that
because it would have taken it back but
it would have been nice 100 people you
would have to hone in on the important
ones yeah yeah then it would kind of
make it obvious like okay well you know
unless this was an actual season of
television like a reality show where oh
that's happening first it got eliminated
damn really into that it would have
definitely ruined some of it because
yeah coming down to the wire there i'm
just like i don't know who that person
is but man am i jealous of them that's
right
and it's like i don't even know who i'm
rooting for i'm just rooting for
somebody to win yes yes yeah but yeah no
you're absolutely right oh it's still
very very entertaining and i can see why
this is going to be a historical video
for this platform man that was awesome
that was awesome mr beast is the bomb
guys subscribe there's still time i
think this has been seven days yet so
i'm in a few days
get that mr b subscription and play the
game and you can win all sorts of things
ten thousand dollars the man who just
gives away money mr b scott oh boy thank
you guys so much for being here you
check out our squid game reactions and
yeah that was amazing zero six seven
jesus christ i know
[Music]
you